today it's great to be joined by
Democratic congressman Adam Schiff who
is a progressive leader in Congress
representing California's 30th District
he is running for Senate hoping to build
an economy that works for everyone and
safeguarder democracy protect the planet
things which really should not be
controversial at this point in time
Congressman great to have you on listen
let me start with what I know is on the
Forefront of many of my viewers Minds
which is
is anybody getting indicted at any point
you know we've been going through this
thing for years and we've been talking
about the former president and
Associates and others where are you on
this issue at this point of what you
expect to see yeah you know I have been
fairly conservative in my expectations
maybe because I don't want to get my
hopes up but also because the justice
department has been so slow to move for
so long they move with alacrity when it
came to the people breaking into the
capital on January 6 and assaulting
police officers but it took them a very
long time to investigate the multiple
efforts multiple lines of effort to
overturn the election the president's
call with the Georgia Secretary of State
for example but also his role in the
incitement of that intact the the
higher-ups in that plot that culminated
on January 6th uh you know we were way
out ahead of them in the investigation
which is a very unusual for congress as
cumbersome as it is to be ahead of the
the justice department yeah
um I I do think the appointment of a
special counsel was a positive sign
because he seems to be you know not not
cautious like the attorney general and
leaning into that investigation finally
um I also uh am very impressed with what
we see out of Fulton County Georgia
uh in many respects I'm more optimistic
about the prosecutor of Fulton County
that I am of the justice department but
I think prudently
we should expect that there's no
prosecutor who will rescue the country
from this danger that we may just very
well have to defeat it at the polls
again uh but I will be happily proven
Wrong by either either prosecutor or the
Manhattan D.A which I think is uh
probably the the least likely candidate
to move forward but nonetheless more
exposure of the president so over the
weekend at a particularly deranged
edition of CPAC uh Donald Trump held
sort of like an impromptu press
conference and was asked some version of
the question if you are indicted however
many times will that interfere with your
presidential run and he said no and the
entire atmosphere at CPAC I don't know
how much you saw but one of the trends
is that the biggest Applause lines are
either homophobic or more recently
transphobic stuff this really seems to
get the modern right excited maybe part
of it is because there's a sort of lack
of policy outside of this sort of
rhetoric How concerned are you about the
degree to which the transgender
Community now seems to be the primary
target of the Maga movement
I'm deeply concerned about it I'm a vice
chair of the quality caucus so this is
an issue I've been very focused on on
behalf of my constituents and you're
right just a couple weeks ago Donald
Trump did a video from Mar-A-Lago the
whole purpose of which was to demonize
the trans Community uh basically to I
guess show his GOP Trump Maga base that
he's even worse on those issues than Ron
DeSantis and this is the the kind of
primary that's going on in the GOP which
is who can most dehumanize one of the
most vulnerable populations in the
country one that has a very high tragic
a very high suicide rate as well as
being the victim of a lot of violence
directed at the community by others so I
I'm deeply concerned about it this is
what autocrats or would-be autocrats do
they look to the most vulnerable and try
to dehumanize them and it also
I think is a signal of you know other
rights they want to take away from
Americans uh they've taken away or tried
to reproductive Freedom through this
multi-decade effort at the Supreme Court
and they may Target other rights and
freedoms of other Americans particularly
vulnerable ones you know Senator Bernie
Sanders recently in an interview I don't
remember which one had a sort of very
interesting candid moment where he said
listen you know based on how long he's
been doing this and his age am I going
to get Medicare for all past no but am I
maybe going to continue doing things
that get more people Health Care am I
going to make incremental steps sort of
in a sense channeling the idea of Ted
Kennedy of incrementalism and taking
steps forward as as you now are running
for Senate and it's an interesting race
which we will talk about how do you
balance the idea of what you would do if
it were simply up to you and the reality
of partisan gridlock needing 60 votes in
the Senate to accomplish so many
different things the reality that the
moneyed right is still extraordinarily
effective at using fundraising and
lobbying to prevent progress from being
made how do you balance what you would
do if it was just up to you and the
reality of what can be accomplished in a
six-year term
well I I also support Medicare for all
but I'm a big believer that you make
progress where you can make progress
and you know at the end of the day you
can't be Progressive if you're not
willing to make progress I'm enormously
proud of what we did in the Affordable
Care Act which brought Healthcare to
tens of millions of people that didn't
have it otherwise I do think and I was a
vocal Advocate at the time
it was a huge missed opportunity not to
pass the public option when we passed
the Affordable Care Act that would have
been I think the the most substantial
downward driver of cost of anything we
were doing at the time and would have
forced uh not only more reasonable uh
costs for health care but it would have
given us a Model A Medicare for all
model uh to build on so that was a
terrible missed opportunity nonetheless
but I have not passed the Affordable
Care Act because we didn't do that no
I'm glad I supported the final product
even if it wasn't exactly what I wanted
because it has done so much good and I
think we are moving uh inexorably
towards Universal care we just need to
keep the the fire that keep pushing to
get there quicker and I'm still hopeful
we will do it in Bernie Sanders lifetime
uh let on my own uh and uh but I I don't
think we'll let the enemy be the uh or
the good be the enemy of the the perfect
be the only the good excuse me
when it comes to speaking of of age
there's this interesting Dynamic that's
developed over in the Republican
presidential primary where Nikki Haley
announced that she's running and when
she's been asked numerous times why
would someone vote for you instead of
trump sometimes she's visibly confused
and when she's able to put together an
answer it's usually about identity
despite claiming to be against identity
politics she's put together well I'm
younger I'm a woman and I'm a of a
minority background of Indian background
in your Senate race the retiring the
outgoing Senator Dianne Feinstein is
around 90 years old the you're running
early 60s Katie Porter's 49 Barbara
released 76 years old how important to
you do you think this idea of Democrats
needing a new generation in power how
important do you think that is
you know I think it really depends
entirely on the person you know so many
young people are enthusiastic supporters
of Bernie Sanders not because of his age
but because a lot of his ideas are new
and his ideas appeal to young people uh
that to me I think is more important
than what the age of the person is that
is what are they advocating what's their
ability to get things done uh and so
people often make that synonymous with
age but it's not always the case and I
think you know Joe Biden has been able
to achieve great things for the country
uh including one of the most aggressive
attacks on climate change in our history
you might not expect that from a
president of his age but nonetheless uh
you know he's been I think very
effective and very Progressive at the
same time voters are going to consider
these factors voters are going to look
at age they're going to look at gender
they're going to look at race and they
should look at all these things they're
also going to look at who can deliver
for gal who's going to get things done
who's going to improve the quality of my
life who's going to help make sure I can
live in a in a good neighborhood with
good public schools that my kids will be
able to afford higher education won't be
saddled with that who is going to make
sure we can drink the water and breathe
the air at the end of the day looking
for people who will deliver for
California and I think they will look
for that regardless of age I I think
they will look at who's got the track
record of getting things done what when
it comes to something like tax policy to
pick something extremely both
substantive and and concrete there's the
very general idea of the rich should pay
more on the right you have ideas from
Flat taxes to cutting taxes for the rich
all sorts of different ideas right now
we have a system where the highest tax
bracket federally 37 percent around half
a million dollars in income I know
that's not exact I don't remember if
it's 460 or 520 this year or exactly
where it is in your ideal tax program
how much higher than 37 do you go if at
all and where would those higher tax
brackets start and one of the things I
find is whenever I ask elected officials
this rarely do I get numbers as answers
yeah well and I don't want to disappoint
you because I don't have a target number
either so okay
but uh you know a big part of why I'm
running is to make the economy work for
everyone uh in a way that is just not
working right now and and a big chunk
that is the tax code uh when I was a kid
my father was a Salesman he made
eighteen thousand dollars a year he
bought a house for our family he had my
mother that cost eighteen thousand
dollars you can't do that now and not
all of it is uh you know the the as my
Republican colleagues would like to
believe the product of some kind of
impersonal Market forces or Adam Smith's
invisible hand a lot of the reason why
the economy isn't working is the product
of a very visible hand of a very
powerful lobbyist or a very powerful
corporate interest in terms of the tax
code when we more than double for
example the child tax credit yeah that
lifted 40 of the kids out of poverty and
when that was allowed to lapse Millions
fell back into poverty that was a policy
choice we made and it's a terrible
policy choice so I would begin in terms
of reforming the tax code more than
doubling the child tax credit I would
begin by providing very generous uh tax
subsidies for people trying to afford
child care so we have accessible
affordable child care so more uh women
in particular but men too can enter the
job Force because they can afford
quality child care I would do away with
how we treat the carried interest of
hedge fund managers who get a enormous
tax break they're some of the wealthiest
people in the country and I get that
break not because it makes sense it
doesn't but because they have very
powerful uh interest lobbying for them
so a lot of these changes would make the
tax code far more Progressive in
addition to however we treat the the top
top line uh rate payers would you like
to see a top rate that is hired than 37
percent
I'm certainly open to that so that we
have a tax code that is more Progressive
I just don't know they can give you the
the ideal number yeah
um but I think and going beyond the tax
code there are innumerable ways that we
can make the economy uh work better for
people uh where we can incentivize uh
the construction of more housing that's
affordable where we can ease the you
know the debt that students are forced
to live under all of which I would put
under the category of making the economy
work for people again let's talk about
the cost of college a little bit since
you mentioned that so I'm trying to
figure out so my daughter is eight
months old I started the 529 right I'm
I'm pretending as though the world is
normal and it's going to be the same in
18 years when it comes time for her to
have the opportunity to go to college
but I'm also doing the math and I know
that for her to go to the same school
that I or my girlfriend went to if costs
keep going up at the same rate rate that
they have been over the last 20 years
it'll be about two hundred and five
thousand dollars per year for tuition
when she is 18. it sounds like that
can't possibly happen like that
something has to break in the next 17
and a half years or or not right I mean
if if student lending continues to stay
the way it is and and people can just
get loan I mean just the numbers don't
seem to make any sense
they don't make any sense and and uh
it's a tragedy the way we funded higher
education essentially on the back of
students
um I I can relate a bit uh when I
graduated uh from uh graduate school my
loans were at 9 12 and 14 interest uh
and my my loan payments were higher than
my rent for about the next 10 years
right I went into the law where I could
afford to pay them off which most people
don't have that luxury and it obviously
circumscribes what they can do with
their careers whether they can follow
their passion it's just a terrible way
to fund education and I do think we need
a complete restructuring so that we
don't you know put on the backs of
students the obligation to uh to pay for
higher education this way it is
unsustainable and uh and and sadly this
should have been done years ago so the
people that have the debt now didn't
have to incur it and we cannot have a
situation where your kid kids are going
to have to pay 200k a year that's just
going to mean ired is only available to
the wealthiest Americans so we need to
change how we fund it we need to change
the whole structure of it uh we ought to
I think Begin by forgiving uh student
debt uh and we certainly shouldn't be uh
forcing students to pay the government
interest on their student loans uh we
shouldn't be the federal government
shouldn't be earning any kind of Revenue
or profit from that a couple other
things in the in the limited time we
have from a political strategy
perspective I'm curious you know there's
this discussion now about the the
Republican primary for 24 and what it
will mean in a trickle-down sense
including for races like yours and in
the House of Representatives and others
there is one feeling that if someone
like Ron DeSantis were to run that uh he
would be if he became the president
significantly more dangerous than Donald
Trump in that he is more committed less
distractible and potentially more
effective at doing really dangerous
authoritarian things and so in some
sense the country would be better off
with Donald Trump as the nominee because
it would he would not only be more
beatable if he was President he would
accomplish fewer dangerous things and
when it comes to races like yours his
presence on the ticket may Inspire more
turnout and help progressives and
Democrats across the country do you have
a view on the Strategic aspect of what
happens in that Republican primary
I do and I would put myself squarely I
guess in the opposite Camp uh I know
many Democrats feel like they would like
even aside from who became president
they would like Trump as the nominee
because they believe he'd be easier to
beat yes um he might be easier to beat
than Ron DeSantis but the danger of his
presidency of a second president to me
is such a a horrible prospect that I
don't even
um endure the possibility uh now not
that I have any say who becomes a
republican nominee but I would rather
have the tougher person to beat than the
even the prospect that Donald Trump
could be successful in general election
I I do think that he is although he's
not as bright as the santis
um he is a uniquely talented grifter yes
uniquely dangerous and shrewd divider of
peoples uh and so I think he would just
tear the country apart
um DeSantis would be a different kind of
a horror show but but to me
um
Trump learned from the first four years
uh and you know he started out with a
couple people of stature uh like
secretary Mattis uh and consecutively
got rid of anyone who had any
independent gravitas to stand up to him
right and and put in place increasingly
sycophantic people
um he would start out with the worst of
the worst if he got another term uh and
yeah and one thing we did see with him
is that each abuse of Presidential Power
was followed by an even worse one
culminating in Insurrection so uh to me
anything is preferable to that when he
started saying your head is like a
watermelon were you hoping he would pick
a different fruit or vegetable although
watermelon is a great it's delicious but
I don't what's your reaction to that
well my reaction was you know he went
from calling me a pencil neck to a
watermelon head and let me just say a
watermelon head on a pencil neck is a
pretty tough balance yes it is but my my
predominant uh thought on the uh on the
various nicknames was you know I thought
he was better at it than that uh the
whole you know cardinal rule of
nicknames is you pick one and you stick
to it yes uh and he's had about eight of
them for me over the years and uh and so
I I don't think they've been as
effective as they could be uh if he just
stuck to one it is interesting that he
always puts a caveat when he mentions
you that you're a bright guy I it's I
don't do you have any insight as to why
he just kind of mentions that every
single time you know it is it is
interesting when I met him in the Oval
Office during the whole Devin Nunes
midnight run thing yep he came out from
behind the Resolute desk where I have to
say he looked it looked like the cover
of Mad Magazine to me he definitely did
not belong in that picture he comes out
from behind the desk the first thing he
does when he shakes my hand and says you
know you do a really good job uh
presumably he means on TV oh that that I
understood because that's what he that's
what impresses him how you do on TV
um but I tell you it was pretty awkward
because when somebody says something
like that to you you know you do a
really good job the first human impulse
is to want to say well so do you but
there was no way I could bring myself to
saying that so it was quite an awkward
pause after that comment that's a thank
you sir moment as and it would become
one of his sir anecdotes that he's known
for uh Democratic congressman Adam
Schiff is running in California for the
senate seat being vacated by long time
Senator Dianne Feinstein I know you're
busy I really appreciate your time and
your insights today great to be with you
thanks for having me on